[Music]
guys have you heard of the town
called asbestos
are people moving yeah are people moving
no
in out i like the name
80s inn now out that's what i think
where do you think this is located in
asbestos yeah
which is indiana just kidding
no country um it sounds it could be
italian
pestos pestos that's interesting oh like
pesto
oh yeah if you say any name with this
then i'm like that's italian that's true
no last one spain japan
nope nope nope okay canada oh
our neighbors yeah our northern
neighbors they have a town in quebec
named after the deadly substance nice
was it actually like
after the substance it was it was
actually the substance asbestos was
mined here oh
oh that makes a lot of sense why it
would be called that yeah yes
what was was the was the substance named
after the town or the town named after
the substance then ah
i don't know which one came first but
all i know is that asbestos was mined
there
so i'm assuming the town was named after
the material yeah anyway the reason why
we're talking about this town is because
they are recently looking for a new name
they're saying that the names are
rebranding it it turns
business like businesses from settling
in this town so it's like hurting
the town's economy sort of so in order
for them to have more opportunities then
business opportunities are looking into
changing their name and so
they have chosen from a list of 1 000
suggestions
fracking
like fracking just has a ring to it that
that reminds us of the old asbestos
you want to live in depleted uranium
canada
well uh they narrowed it down to four
and one of his phoenix
for the mythical bird reborn from fire
okay what are they a 13 year old girl i
mean asbestos you could never even be
put on fire so i don't know
how does arizona feel about that it says
though asbestos exposure is often a
concern after major fires
but yeah yeah yeah that's the a linkage
wait
what's the rundown of what asbestos is
asbestos right now it's like according
to glass
yeah it's kind of like um it's kind of
like a fiberglassy kind of material that
they use
in a lot of products because it was one
cheap too
strong so it has structural integrity
and it was also very flame proof
and insulating super insulation what's
the bad part about it
it goes in your lungs and it never
leaves your lungs or you breathe it in
and it doesn't go away
yeah so your body can't like take it out
yeah got it
yeah so the definition is a heat
resistant fibrous
silica silicate material a mineral
that can be woven into fabrics and is
used in fire resistant and in
insulating materials such as brake
linings when you look at it it looks
like like cotton or something like it
doesn't even look like what you think
fun fact i have a lot of in my lungs
so i renovated my house here uh i found
out
afterwards that the tiles were asbestos
tiles
no and i did not do it i did not
remove the tiles in a very uh safe or
correct way was there was a hammer
involved
breaking the pieces to bits to remove it
yeah i was just like
nope nope nope nope breathing it in yeah
look forward to more fun facts
from nelson we found out it was espresso
styles through tiktok yeah thanks tiktok
how'd you find that out that's asbestos
i'm like really
that's interesting thank you experts
oh yeah so you never actually found out
for sure like a thousand
a lot of carpenters stuff yeah yeah i
looked it up and stuff it was just like
uh
back then common nine inch by nine inch
tiles were all made of asbestos
and yeah well
anyway back to this town so like i said
phoenix is one of them
another option is apollon after a
species of
turtle um or
troll locks or which is three lakes
and f which is a neighborhood in the
town as well
and then the final contender here is
simply just
jeffrey winner
is there a is there an important person
in the in the town named jeffrey
yeah but that's not fun that way
something about jeffrey
campbell canada but it's actually it's
actually the name of what was
until recently the town's largest
asbestos mine
oh the establishment of get away from it
yeah
was funded in 1880 by a w.h
jeffery that's who mined that's who
funded
this mine it's a less offensive way of
naming your town
after christmas yeah yeah so that's it's
actually split the town
because there's seven thousand residents
in this town
and a lot of that we're like seems like
half of them believe like
we should go far away from this name
like far away from the
history of asbestos in our in our town
and we should just go in a different
direction and the other half is like
but this is our town's history like we
should at least honor it somewhat and
also because they have
they have family they have families that
like family members that
were part of that industry that actually
mined asbestos
and they're all dead
you know fun fact i told you it was
coming tick tock fast
tick tock confirmed it tick-tock
confirmed everyone did
that's how it works yeah so they're
saying residents aged 14 and above
are asked to rank the four names in
their order of preference they don't
want that
i want to know what 13 and below i think
jeffrey
and what they would have actually like
submitted as well and i wonder what the
other
names we want dick but
think about's a good name oh no that's
solid
dude it's kind of like have you seen all
those like internet uh like
like surveys or polls or whatever we're
like mountain dew's like oh we're gonna
name like the next
you know soda or whatever after whatever
you guys love the internet when they
[ __ ]
4chan gets a hold of it and the top top
one is like granny squirt
oh no and then it wins and then they're
just like they just take the whole
contest
they delete their entire book never
existed in campaign
what was the other one yeah i
i'm i'm kind of upset that they didn't
end up naming the boat that means he's
not even offended it's not offensive
boaty mcboat so good yeah
dude oh me and nicky were in hawaii uh
in bahamas we saw
all kinds of shits what was the worst
people like name their own boats
yeah yeah i saw one and it was like the
i don't know the saharan queen or
something
and i was just like i know what you
think your boat looks like but it
doesn't look like it it's like a little
it's like a little like wrap exactly and
it was offensive to me that they thought
it looked that tight
to name it like a queen yeah yeah yeah
but i'm like what would you have named
it yourself
that boat yeah uh a five out of ten
they come on board the ss five out of
ten
captain steve we'll show you around
before she's a five
exclamation point okay yeah that fits
[Laughter]
oh yeah so that's kind of fun
trying to think of a new name for a town
yeah just don't let the internet get
ahold of you
yeah or please do or yeah it makes
everything more fun
yeah i mean i like i like the idea of
the jeffrey one not just because it
sounds funny and plain
but also a lot i like alluding to the
history without
actually saying it you know not like
cutting out completely because i'm sure
like the major part of the economy that
town was based off of yes
even though it was like terrible we
found out later on but at the time it
was pretty good
but shouldn't most cities be renamed for
the coolest [ __ ] that happened there
like [ __ ] skywalker ranch is in marin
county right
uh or something like that yes yeah but
like marin county like who gives a [ __ ]
like what does that mean
like rename that [ __ ] skywalker [ __ ]
county or something
oh that'd be tight it's in look at
anaheim dude it's basically called
disney town
so do you think do they have to change
the game as soon as something cool
happens i think they should yeah
we think of that fast-changing world
yeah let's keep it going you live in
skywalker or marin
or the tom now i live in
fire city formerly known as l.a
smog city yes smog city there are flaws
in my idea i will say
true then uh name it what's the place
where there's a whole bunch of tents i'm
totally blinking
tent city
ten cities are yeah what the [ __ ]
i'm like i was blinking i was thinking
something yeah i wasn't thinking
i was literally thinking a community
full of tents and i'm like where is that
it really depends that's where it is
tent city also sounds like
some like you know like rv world it's
like
come on bye we got tits for days i got
small tips big tips
long term short tests huh i still i want
to see those local commercials like do
they still do you still have like local
tv like do you still do tv yeah you
that's where you need to get the good
local commercials
we got purple tabs we got black tests we
got what green tents come on now oh no i
love that [ __ ] yeah
red link they need to stop making their
podcast and go back to making local
commercials
yeah that was so good back then yeah
that was their whole big thing on
youtube for a while because they were
making local commercials
for businesses and they leaned into the
local commercials like
vibe oh it's so good you have to look it
up classics of youtube
i miss local commercials period man
because i don't i don't see them anymore
because i'm only on youtubes and all
this other [ __ ] well i only see them if
i find compilations on youtube of like
local commercials
sometimes they sneak in though like if
i'm watching something on youtube and
then there's like
an ad yeah oh yeah they're getting more
localized yeah they'll be there and i'm
like
oh it's funny because you're like used
to listening you know what you're
programmed to listen to an ad and be
like yeah that's an ad and i'll send you
here like
this really like distant voice and be
like hey come on down in roger's
warehouse
what the [ __ ] yeah dude my new thing now
is just that guy being like
hey you you're the owner of this [ __ ]
i'm thinking
your coffee [ __ ] i'm like i'm wearing my
deodorant
i like it imagine that i'm wearing your
deodorant
[ __ ] yeah right exactly all those
chemicals i just feel attacked
yeah when they're like just purposely
trying to rile you up to get you to
listen to this brand
sometimes they get me though on these
like youtube ads because then i'll start
off like really enticing i'm like
[ __ ] i actually want to find out more
like what the [ __ ] else are you talking
about there was this one about this bra
that
is talking about how like when you wear
a bra like too
tight it like [ __ ] up the the tissue
and your breasts and all this stuff
and i actually got interested because
the actress was
uh she comes out on five minute crafts
on instagram i'm always scrolling
through and i'm like hey she got a new
gig
so like let me check this out
and then i got really interested in the
[ __ ] bra i was like what the [ __ ]
kind of bra is this i actually don't
even remember the brand and i didn't
watch the rest of the effective
commercial
at least we know that guy hates my
deodorant i don't know what he's selling
yeah he hates money he's selling you
insurance he's like hey your deodorant
sucks
but have you considered life insurance
because he's very mad at my deodorant
i talked about commercials oh it's never
about geico
that's that's what makes them memorable
it's never about what geico
oh you know how it's always like the
most random [ __ ] and it goes geico
yeah but if i start to say it can save
you
you already know where i'm going and
that's how they [ __ ] you
so hard in the head five percent or more
on car insurance no because they changed
it
i remember it used to be different and
then they changed it
because of like legalities or some [ __ ]
and then guys who can save you fifteen
percent or more on cards
fifteen percent yeah now they don't i
don't think they say that anymore
no they do no it's a dif well okay i'll
i'm wrong
i'm wrong i will fight i will fight you
i'm wrong you guys
know i'm right i watched 35 of these
commercials a day i will literally fight
you right
look at some from like 10 years ago and
compared to the one from today they say
they say it differently
steve is a commercial connoisseur thank
you
you